no one knows if or when the train will
come
but in the city of dinipro there are
thousands of people keeping watch
their past and their present has been
packed into bags
while their future lies on platform one
the trains head west to the city of la
vie which stands as some sort of beacon
but nobody wants to leave their home
how do you feel very bad very very bad
i i am very angry
why
because putin
weighty decisions are made in a moment
by those who have no time to think how
do you feel in your heart
[Music]
it's beginning to slow down now and
there is going to be one almighty
crush
as people try to get on
this map's not in a good way
but they're going to get him on
propelled by fear they battle to board
as the train attendants beg them to step
back
bags are hoisted from passenger to
passenger and within a few minutes the
train is full
the majority on this train are women and
children
men between 18 and 60 are expected to
stay and fight
so those on board made their solitary
farewells
natalia necrasa is taking her son to
safety her husband
i asked her where she was planning to go
some feel shame for leaving their loved
ones
others struggle to make sense of it as
the train speeds them away from the
front lines
oleg is from the city of vallnavaca
um
[Music]
the train stops in towns and villages as
we travel through the night and on every
platform there are people trying to get
in
what are they doing they can't get on
says one
the conductor refuses to open the doors
irina and her son have been traveling
for days after her hometown was attacked
by the russians
she says she'll never be the same
[Music]
sound of air raid sirens a reminder of
everything they left behind
so the majority will continue this
journey moving west into the arms of the
european union
a great exodus of reluctant travelers
wondering if they'll ever make it home
john sparks sky news in western ukraine